[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOANNA SCHAFFHAUSEN: Hi.
And thank you so much for
coming today and taking time out
of your very busy schedules
to listen to me yammer
on about my book.
It's called "The
Vanishing Season,"
and it just came out last week.
And it had an unusual path
to publication in that it won
the Mystery Writers
of America/St.
Martin's Minotaur Debut
Crime Novel Award,
which is an annual contest that
is held in conjunction with St.
Martin's-- my publisher--
and the Mystery
Writers of America.
So it's open to anybody who
has an unpublished manuscript.
So if you have an
unpublished manuscript lying
around that has
to do with crime,
you can shine it
up and send it in.
The new deadline is
mid-January of 2018.
And they usually get
about 400 submissions.
And the Mystery
Writers of America
have some judges who comb
through those manuscripts
and narrow it down to a handful
of finalists, which are then
sent on to the editors at St.
Martin's, who pick the winner.
And occasionally,
there's no winner.
But my year, I won,
which I was very
surprised and
delighted to find out,
which is how my book came to be.
So that was March 2016 when
they said, yes, we like it.
We will publish it.
And it just came out now,
about 22 months later.
So it's a long journey
from the decision
to publish to the actual
presentation of the book.
But it's been exciting and fun.
I recommend it.
You know.
And so the book is about--
one of the reasons I thought
that it might not win
is most of the winners have
been traditional mysteries
or historical mysteries that
don't feature a lot of grit
or, well, body parts, as
my mother calls my novel
The Body Parts Novel.
So I was very
surprised when they
picked me and my body parts--
delighted but surprised.
And it's about a
serial killer who's
active in a small town in
Woodbury, Massachusetts.
It's fictional.
And living in this town is
my heroine, Ellery Hathaway,
who has personal knowledge
of a serial killer,
because she was kidnapped
off the streets of Chicago
as a 14-year-old-- the eve of
her 14th birthday, actually.
She was alone, outside
on the streets at night,
because her mother
was in the hospital
with her brother who
was dying of cancer.
And the father had
run off years ago.
So Ellery was vulnerable.
And when the sedan pulled
over-- it's a hot July night
in Chicago, oppressive heat--
she thought, well, if
I help him, maybe he'll
give me $1 for a soda
and I can cool off.
But instead, he
got out of the car,
and her life changed forever.
She would have been
victim number 17
of Francis Coben, who's an
infamous Ted-Bundy-type serial
killer who had abducted
and killed 16 girls before.
And he kept the hands
and ditched the rest.
And so Ellery was
imprisoned by him
and would have been killed too
if not for a very green FBI
agent who was low
man on the totem
pole in the investigation.
But he played a hunch and
serendipitously rescued her
from the closet.
And that was 14 years
before the book opens.
And now she's
living in anonymity.
She's changed her name.
She's trying to put all
the past behind her.
But every year
around her birthday,
somebody goes missing
from this small town.
And they all seem to have--
well, most of them seem to
have reasons to be missing.
So nobody is very surprised.
And they aren't looking for
them too hard in most cases,
and they don't see a pattern.
But Ellery gets a creepy clown
birthday card in the mail
after each disappearance that
says "Happy Birthday, Ellery."
And she doesn't really talk
about her birthday much,
so this is a signal
to her that somebody
knows who she is for real and
the person may be dangerous.
But she can't get
anybody to believe her
that these disappearances
are connected.
And to explain the whole
story risks outing her past
and again being forced to deal
with this ugly serial killer
who had hurt her when
she was a teenager.
So this year the vanishing
season is coming around again,
and somebody is going to
go missing unless she can
figure out a way to stop it.
So she calls up the one guy
she knows who will believe her,
and that's Reed Markham, the
FBI agent who rescued her
when she was 14.
And Reed's life skyrocketed
after his rescue of Ellery.
He wrote a bestselling
book about it,
he got promoted, he
became a hotshot profiler.
It was great.
He met his wife
this way where she
was starstruck a little by
the whole serial killer-- you
catch serial killers,
that's really cool.
And so the best time
of his life, basically,
is the worst time of Ellery's.
And that's why they're
interesting to put together,
is they had their
identities forged
by this initial terrible
case, and they've both
been living with it in
different ways ever since.
So for Reed, it's been a boon--
gave him fame and fortune.
And for Ellery, it has
been awful, obviously.
And so forcing them
back together again
causes them to
confront those roles
where, for Reed, if
Ellery's life isn't
awesome-- he's
always told himself
he's the big hero of her story.
He rescued her, she's
the one that lived--
if her life isn't so awesome,
then maybe he's not the hero
he told himself he was.
And for Ellery, she's
always told herself
she's going to be
the victim forever.
She's forever tied to this
very famous serial killer.
And so now she has a chance
to see who she might be apart
from that story.
So that's the main
thrust of the book.
And one of the
questions I get asked
a lot is where did it come from.
And the genesis of the
story was about 20 years ago
I was reading one of the
stories about Ted Bundy.
And there are a lot of them.
There's a new Ted
Bundy story every year,
basically-- a movie, a TV
movie, a book, something.
This story, it's 40 years old,
but it keeps getting retold,
and so Ted Bundy lives on.
And for the people who were
caught up in his story,
this can be difficult to
have to keep reliving it
when the public won't
let it die, basically.
And so he has living
victims, one of whom
is a woman named Carol DaRonch.
Carol was 18 and shopping
at a Utah shopping mall
when Ted Bundy, pretending
to be a police officer,
told her that her car
had been broken into
and she needed to come with
him to the police station
and make a report.
And so she got into
the car with him
and was immediately
struck that this
doesn't look like a cop's car.
And then he drove her not
towards the police station
but away from it.
And so she freaked
out and demanded
to be let out of the
car, at which point
Bundy realized
that the jig was up
and he had to
subdue her somehow.
So he pulled over to
the side of the road,
and he tried to snap
his handcuffs on her.
But in the struggle, he got
both the cuffs on one wrist,
and so she was able to escape.
And she became the beginning
of Ted Bundy's end,
because people knew that he was
out there, this guy named Ted,
and there were
the missing girls,
and they were
probably connected.
But they didn't know
what he looked like,
all these sort of things.
And she was able
to say, here's what
he looked like, here's
the car he was driving.
And the cops were able to start
putting the pieces together.
So Carol today-- so, more than
40 years after this incident--
still gets 10 to 15 messages
per day about Ted Bundy.
People write her saying,
oh, he kidnapped me, too.
Or they say, tell me what Ted's
really like, what was it like?
They want her story.
A couple of years ago, some guy
decided to say he was her son
and he has this
connection to Ted Bundy.
She doesn't have a son.
So she was forced to either
let this lie perpetuate
or to come forward and
say, I don't have a son.
He's lying.
So Bundy's been
dead for decades.
He was electrocuted
in Florida in 1989.
But for Carol, he's
there every day.
Her life now became
about Ted Bundy.
And the public won't
let him go for her.
She has no choice.
Another person caught up
in the Ted Bundy story
would be the Reed
Markham type character.
And this was Bob Keppel,
who was brand new.
He had been on the job
as a homicide detective
one week when he got
handed the Ted Bundy case.
And this completely changed the
trajectory of Keppel's career.
He ended up specializing
in serial murder.
He hunted Bundy for years
until they caught him.
When Bundy was finally
apprehended for good--
because he escaped twice--
he was finally apprehended
for good in Florida.
Keppel traveled there and
interviewed him multiple times
and was able to get Bundy
to confess to more murders
that they didn't know
he'd even committed.
Eventually, Keppel went on to
specialize in serial murder
and try to help classify them
to see if we could figure out
how to get serial
killers, learn more about
how they think, where
did they come from.
So he participated in
some scientific research.
He ended up lecturing,
teaching about serial killers.
It also took over his life,
in a more positive way,
in that he was the
expert in serial murder.
But again, it was
serendipity, right?
He's just a guy working
for the Seattle Police
when all of a sudden this call
comes in about a missing girl.
And now he's been handed one
of the most infamous cases
in all of history.
So I was less struck when I
read this book about Ted Bundy
himself-- he's
very interesting--
but all of these side
people, the people who
were approached by Bundy
and didn't go with him.
So I know somebody who was
living in the sorority house
that he attacked in Florida.
He broke in and just
basically went from room
to room beating women, these
young women, with a log.
And he killed some of them
and gravely injured others.
There was one who was
going to be a dancer,
and the head injury
caused her life
to be rewritten because she
had balance issues after that.
And so she lived, but her
life was never the same.
And the woman I know lived there
but wasn't home that night.
She was out.
So it's the sliding
doors, parallel lives--
what if she had been there.
She wasn't.
But still, it's something
she thinks about frequently.
When you have a brush with
an infamous case like this,
it changes you.
And so the book is
about serial murder.
And there's a mystery,
and who did it,
and all that other stuff.
But it's also about what
it's like to live attached
to this infamous crime.
How many people are familiar
with "Mindhunter," very popular
Netflix series right now?
I see one.
So "Mindhunter" is
based on the work
of two other people who
hunted serial killers, Ressler
and Douglas.
And they went around
and interviewed them.
They had this idea--
serial killers have
been with us forever,
but nobody really studied them.
And they said, well, we're going
to study them and interview
them.
And see if we can classify
them and figure out
where they come from and
help people catch them.
So this is all about
their interviews.
They have people playing
creepy serial killers,
and they show the interviews
and how the work came to be,
and whether people
supported it at first,
and how it gained momentum.
What's interesting about it now
is if you go to the FBI site,
the FBI is basically like, yeah,
none of that really panned out.
We tried, but it turns
out serial killers
are very hard to catch.
And they're hard to catch
for a lot of reasons.
But one of the things
is all their hard work
at trying to figure
out, OK, what can we
say about serial killers.
And they could find some
tendencies like, OK, they
tend to be bed-wetters
into later adolescence--
so bed-wetting is a problem
even when they're 10, or 12,
or something like that.
OK.
Well, if you suspect
you have a serial killer
in your neighborhood and
you're a police officer,
you can't really go
round up the bed-wetters.
So the cops are looking
at these profiles going,
they don't help us.
OK, so he had mommy issues.
How do we go round up the
people who had mommy issues
or whatever?
This is not helpful.
And then also some
of it just turns out
not to be helpful even as
a classification system.
So one of the big things
they tried early on
was you could be an
organized killer who
would be kind of like Bundy,
who planned his victims.
And he had this
very big ruse where
he would dress up as an
injured person with a cast on.
And he'd say, oh,
come with me, I
need you to help me
carry my books to my car.
And the young women would
go with him, at which point
he would leap upon
them and subdue them.
Or he would pretend to be a
cop or something like that.
And he had a plan
with how he was
going to be with the
victim, and kill her,
and where he was
going to leave her.
And then disorganized
killers, who would be like,
ooh, I'm just walking along
when I am overcome with the urge
to kill.
And I break in and
I just kill people.
But Bundy did that,
too, at the end.
So is he organized
or disorganized?
And it turns out organized
killers have elements
that are disorganized,
and disorganized killers
have elements of organization.
So this category
helped not at all.
But there are other things
that are kind of interesting,
things that appear about
serial killers in movies
and television.
So for example, you see
things like, oh, they always
take trophies with them.
That's a big thing.
And it turns out about half--
half take some sort of trophy,
like some piece of the victim's
jewelry or a driver's
license, so they
can relive it afterward.
But only about half.
Another one-- they
found serial killers
are more likely to have
served in the military.
So if 1% of the
population has served
in the military around
now, serial killers
it's one in three.
So probably they're attracted to
the dominance, and the weapons,
and that sort of thing.
But again, the vast majority
of people in the military
are not serial killers.
So even if you suspect
you have a serial killer,
it's not like you can go round
up everybody in the military
and say, are you the one?
And then, let's see,
other things that
are true about serial killers--
that they kill
strangers and that's
why they're hard to catch.
And it turns out about a third
of their victims are strangers.
It turns out the most
common relationship
between a serial killer
and his victim is business.
So watch out when
you're doing business.
Now, prostitution accounts
for a good chunk of that.
That's classified as business.
But also, you go down
to your Kinko's to make
some mimeographs or whatever
and the serial killer
happens to be working
behind the counter.
So you get those
kind of things, too,
where there's this
casual connection.
You would still
mostly be classified
as strangers-- you don't
really know each other--
but you have met before.
So that's another thing
that is interesting
about serial killers.
Another one that
pops up sometimes
is are the victims all women.
On TV, they're
almost always women.
And it turns out in real life
they're mostly women, too.
It's about 80%.
And again, part of that
is the prostitution.
Because if you're a serial
killer, and you're lazy,
and you want a
victim, it's very easy
to get a prostitute to
get in the car with you.
You don't have to go hunt her.
Open the door and she'll get in.
And then you are
expected to drive
her off somewhere
secluded, so she
doesn't freak out immediately.
So unfortunately, people
who are in the sex trade
are still vulnerable
to this kind of thing.
You can call them up and have
one delivered to your home.
So that's a chunk of
where that comes from.
So it's about 80% of
the victims are women.
And another one that I
find interesting-- there's
this idea that, oh, they're
already in the system
somewhere.
If we just look for people
who are out there committing
violent crimes, we can
find the serial killer.
And it turns out, no,
that about 80% of them
have some kind of record by
the time they are arrested
for murder, but it's
usually nonviolent stuff
like peeping or simple theft.
It's not really that
they're out there committing
these violent crimes,
and they have a record.
So it turns out they're actually
very, very hard to catch.
I got some feedback on my
book actually about Reed,
and his ability to
profile, and everything.
And somebody would be like,
he's not very good at his job.
He gets stuff wrong in the book.
And, well, profiling is
not a science, per se.
It's not like it has the
guaranteed outcome that they're
like, OK, and he's going
to be wearing a red sweater
and driving a blue minivan.
They can't get it down that far.
And indeed, the cops often
get frustrated because what
the profilers will come
forward with are stuff
like, well, he's
really angry at women.
And the cops are
like, yeah, we kind of
gathered that from the
way he's killing them.
What else you got?
Nothing?
Oh, the bed-wetter thing, OK.
So there is this
tension between the FBI
that wants to do this
research into serial killers,
and the local police, who really
just want help catching them
when they think they have one.
But this is another
problem, is how
do you know when you have one.
Because it'd be nice if they
were always very consistent
and they left the signed
notes like the Zodiac--
ooh, it's me.
Or they always used
a pair of red nylons
to strangle their victim,
something obvious that says,
OK, yeah, these are all related.
But sometimes
they're opportunists,
and they will change
murder weapons.
And so one might
be a strangulation
and then another
will be a shooting.
So they can be very
hard to detect.
But what's interesting
now is some people
are beginning to
experiment with big data.
And it's hard right now because
the way law enforcement works,
they're all segregated.
So you can be a serial
killer in one town,
and go across the street
and be a serial killer
in another town, and
the two towns don't even
know that they have related
victims because they're not
sharing data.
So there are some people
who are making efforts
to try and get the police
departments to share more data
so you can pick
out serial killers.
And that's looking like it
might be an interesting way.
Some people are saying
that this will work,
but it hasn't been
rigorously tested yet.
But at least we
are probably moving
in the right direction to
being able to spot these guys.
And again, it is mostly guys.
You can get female
serial killers.
They tend to murder
serial husbands,
like black widows-- like, I'll
marry a guy and then off him
for money, and then I'll marry
another one, off him for money.
And if you move around, this
can be very hard to catch.
And this is the thing--
how do they finally
catch serial killers?
Well, it turns
out their families
turn them in, their friends,
the people who know them,
who can say, oh, yeah,
he was a bed-wetter.
Yeah.
Or in Bundy's case,
his fiancee was like,
he has plaster of
Paris in the bathroom
and some handcuffs in the car.
That looks suspicious to me.
She had to turn
him in three times
before they took her seriously,
because nobody thought they
were looking for a law student.
They thought they were looking
for some sort of savage
on the street who was foaming
at the mouth or something.
So it took a while.
Even though lots of
people were turning
Ted in, Ted Bundy, like, ooh,
this guy does drive a VW Bug
and his name is
Ted, the cops just
didn't believe it
could possibly be him
until his girlfriend
actually turned him
in when he moved to
Utah and more women
started disappearing there.
And she's like, OK,
so Ted moved to Utah,
and now you have
missing women there.
You really might want
to check into that.
But what's interesting
about Liz, his fiancee--
she didn't break up with him.
It's a head-scratcher for me.
So she kept turning
him in to the cops
like, I think he could
be a serial killer.
I think he might be
the guy, and then I'm
also still going to marry him.
And indeed, one woman did
marry him on death row
when he'd been
convicted of all of it
and actually bore his child.
So out there is
a woman who would
be a little younger than me
who has Ted Bundy for a father.
And her mother is somebody who
had sex with Ted Bundy when
he was on death row.
So that's your
parentage, good luck.
Are there any questions about
publishing, about the book,
about serial murder?
AUDIENCE: I found the addressing
of the emotional scars
in the book interesting.
It really does feel like that
is a major part of the book,
as you said, rather
than just the killer
and the hunt for the killer.
It's hard to make such a thing
come across as believable
unless you have examples of
people with emotional scars
to go on.
I guess to some
extent we all do.
Did you use any particular
examples from the real world
to base Ellery's
behavior and baggage on?
JOANNA SCHAFFHAUSEN: So
I have the Bundy case
as one of the imprints.
But actually I was assaulted
by a neighbor when I was five
repeatedly, by a neighbor
who told me he would kill me
if I ever told my family.
And so I said nothing
for several years.
He eventually went to jail
for unrelated charges.
But I've always wondered
what parts of my personality
are as a result
of that experience
and what would have
been me anyway.
There's no control Joanna
that we can run alongside me
to be able to say, OK, that's
how you would have been
if this had never happened.
So it's something that's
interesting to me.
I started checking
out books on rape
from the library when
I was eight to try
to understand this whole thing.
So I've done a ton of reading.
And I've done writing about it.
And what happens when I write
about it is women come out
of the woodwork and say, yeah,
here's what happened to me.
And so I've been
collecting these stories
over the years of
different women.
And so Ellery is kind of an
amalgamation of all of us.
Her story is very dramatic
because it's famous
and you can't get away from it.
Most of us live in
relative anonymity.
So that part is very
unusual for Ellery.
But what's common is
the shame, the wondering
did I do something to
cause this, the feeling
that if somebody knows what
happened to you that it's
going to change how they
look at you, how they feel,
how they act to you.
We've seen this with the
#MeToo movement, right?
So a lot of women
have some story.
And most of us are carrying
it around in secret.
And just the secrecy part of
it can be a lingering pain.
And so, yeah, Ellery is a
mixture of all of these tales.
Yes, another question?
AUDIENCE: What did you find most
surprising about the publishing
process?
JOANNA SCHAFFHAUSEN:
Most surprising
about the publishing process.
Well, I'm really heartened
that the book is doing well.
To me, that's the
biggest surprise.
I wrote-- it was a nice little
mystery, and I liked it,
but it sold out on
Amazon in six days.
And so people are coming forward
going, I really liked this.
And I'm like, oh, thank you.
I'm just surprised every time.
In terms of the mechanics, I
would say how long it takes.
I knew that intellectually,
but it was 22 months.
And as I like to
say, I could have
birthed two actual children
in that time frame,
or one elephant, or a book.
And it turns out that there's
a lot of different pieces
that go into it.
My publisher publishes
110 mysteries a year.
So you have your slot about this
is when the editor can focus
on your book, this is
when the copy editor can
focus on your book,
this is when the cover
artists can focus on your book.
And it's a complicated
dance, and you
have to meet your steps.
Or the whole process--
you can miss your opening,
and then your book
is delayed even more.
So that has been, I would
say, the most surprising part.
The thing that surprises
other people is I
don't have anything
to do with the cover.
The publisher picks both the
title and the cover for books.
And authors, depending
on their stature,
get more or less input.
And so this title
actually is mine,
and the publisher agreed to it.
The cover, I was
not even consulted.
They're just like, here it is.
And I provided some feedback,
and they made some tweaks
on that.
And I'm very happy with
the way it turned out.
But I know sometimes
authors are very unhappy.
Lisa Gardner was
telling me this week
that they'd tweaked
her cover so many times
that it ended up the
woman had six fingers.
So she's looking at the cover,
she's like, it looks odd to me.
It published this way.
She's like, it looks odd to me.
And her husband, she says,
he's more visual than I am,
and he came along.
He's like, that's because
she has six fingers.
Oh, yeah.
And then even if you
are Lisa Gardner, who
has published
zillions of "New York
Times" bestselling books, still
the publisher will come to you
and say, can you give
the heroine brown eyes?
Or not brown eyes
but green eyes,
because we have
green-eyed art that we
want to use on the cover?
And so brown eyes
aren't going to work.
So can you go back and
change her heritage
so that she has green eyes?
And Lisa is like,
all right, I'll
just go tweak her heritage so
she has green eyes in the book.
So the way the different
pieces come together
and where the
author can push back
and where the author
can't continues
to be a bit of a
surprise for me.
AUDIENCE: Just
quickly, thank you
for that explanation of why
so many books' cover pictures
don't match the story inside.
I never understood.
JOANNA SCHAFFHAUSEN: Yeah.
Well, it turns out
authors actually usually
are not very good at figuring
out what to put on the cover.
Because they imagine that
it's going to be a scene,
like you act out a
scene from the book.
And when it doesn't look
like that, they're like,
but this doesn't
look like my book.
And it turns out that the most
important thing the book can do
is signal its genre,
like what it is.
So is it literary fiction?
Is it a scary mystery?
Is it a cozy mystery
like "Murder, She Wrote"
where there's a dead body
but nobody really cares?
That kind of thing.
Because if you get it wrong,
the readers are angry.
I've seen reviews where there's
something on the cover that's
super creepy, and then
the book isn't scary
and the readers are mad.
They're like, I
really was prepared
to be terrified by this
book, and it wasn't even
mildly thrilling.
Or, this book looks
sci-fi to me and it isn't.
And honestly, even when
you get in the genre,
you can still have problems.
So one of my readers apparently
thinks she looks pregnant.
And so she read the book
expecting the pregnancy
to show up, and it never did.
And she was mad.
She's like, two stars
off, the cover is a lie.
So you can't win.
But really, more than acting
out a particular scene
or having the
character look exactly
like they're
described in the book,
you want it to signal what
it is so that readers--
you don't want somebody
looking for a pizza
to get a cheeseburger.
AUDIENCE: What can you tell
us about your future work?
JOANNA SCHAFFHAUSEN: Oh,
what a great question.
So I'm very fortunate.
St. Martin's has kindly
picked up the next two
books in the series.
So "No Mercy" is slated
to come out January 2019.
And then there is
another one after that.
And it's Reed and Ellery
again and the basset
hound Speed Bump.
Everybody likes the basset
hound, so he's back, too.
And they solve more crimes.
The second book, Ellery is
sentenced to group therapy
with ordinary crime victims.
One of them is a survivor--
his wife was killed
in a drunk driving accident.
Another one had his buddy die
in a convenience store robbery.
So none of them is famous
like Ellery, none of them
has, you know, crime
in big, bold letters.
And Ellery, she's been living
with it all these years.
So she's not too keen on getting
in touch with her feelings.
So instead, some of
these crimes are unsolved
for her fellow survivors.
So she starts trying to
solve all their lives
rather than doing what
she's supposed to.
And then the third one,
Reed, actually, his mother
was murdered when
he was an infant.
She was found stabbed to
death just a short way
away from his crib.
And he was adopted.
And he gets a hot new
lead after 40 years.
And Reed and Ellery go to Vegas
to solve his mother's murder.
AUDIENCE: What would you say is
the surprising part of writing
a book maybe compared
to other stuff you've
written in the past?
JOANNA SCHAFFHAUSEN: Sure,
yeah, surprising part
of writing a book.
Well, I have to
have some surprise.
I discovered very
early on that if I
outline, too much of
a detailed outline,
I won't write the book.
Because it's all like,
well, the hard part
is figuring out the exact
phrasing and everything.
And if the story is all there,
I'm like, well, that's it.
I don't need to do that work.
I'll just leave it in my head.
So I have a rough outline.
And then things happen
where I'm writing along
and a character I
didn't think was going
to do something does something.
All of a sudden it's
happening, and I was like, oh,
that's very interesting.
I didn't know you had
that secret motive.
Or this thing in
your past that's
suddenly coming out to light.
Ian [? McKellen ?] said
he wrote like 13 books
before he realized his
hero was Polish, you know,
like that was his ancestry.
He's like, oh, of course,
you're Polish, I didn't know.
So that's the fun part
is the discovery, where
you're writing along and you
learn about your character.
So that's, I think, the
surprising part and the fun
part.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]